[Music]
this morning in our Saturday sessions
it's been a busy year so far for
singer/songwriter Anderson back in
February he won his first Grammy Award
for Best Rap performance in April he
released his fourth studio album and
this month he begins a national tour
headlining Madison Square Garden
next Thursday we'll hear some of his new
music in just a moment but first I had
the chance to talk with Anderson PAC
here in New York you can hear a world of
influences in Anderson PACs music the
foundation of me is like gospel soul
music you know going up my mom was
assonance like Frankie Beverly and Earth
Wind & Fire but my sisters were into
like where I carry Whitney Houston new
addition our girl in a house full of
women so I was just trying to keep the
peace
pack grew up in Oxnard California you
didn't have an easy childhood know my
pops you know battled with drug abuse
and there was domestic abuse with my mom
and I saw a lot of craziness and then he
went off to jail I never got to really
you know develop like a relationship
with him before he passed away how did
you respond to that how did you feel
about it I put everything into music and
I think there was a part of me that
didn't want people to like pay too much
attention so I kind of just was like
everything's cool man you know I just
put the smile on and was like
everything's all right but then his
mother ended up in jail too for tax
related reasons how old are you at this
point I was like 18 Wow yeah I was a lot
for an 18 year old yeah but I feel like
some people are just built for more
things than others and we do stronger
than you thought you were yeah for sure
you know I didn't I wasn't the type to
just break down and just like okay I'm
just gonna be a bum and just that's it
you know I was like okay I'm gonna be a
square now I'm gonna get a job back
struggle to make ends meet but his heart
was always in music he launched his
career as breezy love joy before
deciding he needed a different identity
[Music]
playing around with his given name
Brandon Pak Anderson he came up with
Anderson PAC
[Music]
sounds prestigious you know it sounds
like the G you know and I put the dot
just give it a little bit of mystery and
a little bit of like extra you know I
can't do anything regular for some
reason so I put the dot and I was like
okay it'll always remind me of detail
and how we got to this point it was as
Anderson PAC buzz started to build then
dr. Dre heard his song swayed he didn't
know who I was and I had to kind of show
and prove and so I got in the studio
with him and closed my eyes up on the
mic open my eyes and Jay is like you've
got that pain like you live
pack has never looked back
and he's a father now - as someone who
essentially didn't have a father
yeah how do you look at fatherhood then
I feel like I'm learning I got two boys
and my boy is smarter faster stronger
and he sees everything I do I can't fool
you know zan like I can't pull my wife
and I can't fool my eight-year-old son
that won't keep you excuse me super
honest
[Music]